the Joe Rogan experience would have been
married how about your boy sage
Northcutt yeah Cosmo hogs animals kill
the guy he's a beast the stage is still
in the hospital 17 fractures in his face
yeah I know he's still not won't you
kill the guy outside as you know Sergey
Kovalev did yeah I know Cole will have
killed a guy in a fight um
Cosmo Alexandra is a world-class Muay
Thai fighter I mean John Wayne Parr
fought him you know he thought Nikki
hold skin he's world class as far as
striking it's a completely different
level but I guess because it was an MMA
fight he was willing to take it but they
say foot they fought stand up [ __ ] man
and sage took that karate stance and the
dude circled off to his right and landed
that [ __ ] right hand and it was on
the possess the hardest right hand I've
ever seen I was can you imagine
just up from a world-class striker with
the flounce gloves on and he's circling
in to the right yeah and it's like a
[ __ ] bomb it's pretty goddamn strong
and cosmos a beast of a man you mean
he's a big thick dude
see I mean a big thick dude with
multiple world titles to his name don't
you feel bad watching us - do you feel
bad for sage yeah it's a terrible
matchup I don't know why they agreed to
let him fight that guy though it's just
not smart because that because the the
kickboxing stand-up like he doesn't have
the experience age is good he's very
good but these these kind of losses are
terrible for a few for his future
because their mismanagement losses in my
opinion I agree I think sage is what 22
like look at that punch the plants I
mean that is ferocious from a
world-class right yeah left full blast -
that is a full blast sugar right you
can't you can't get hit cleaner than
that no you came hip it's be hard to hit
a [ __ ] but meanwhile have you ever
seen him when he fought Nicky
holtz-eakin Cosmo yeah yeah get up class
miss yours can [ __ ] [ __ ]
there's the Devils there's levels but in
MMA
Sage's and even rement be they should be
shin Se marine welcome so why would why
would I bring this this stud this
America
Stud who looks like Ryu from Street
Fighter and go hey first fight here's
the most world-class striker we got in
the roster
well because they want him to be tested
and I think that if I was chatri I would
be looking at it like this when a guy
like Eddie Alvarez gets ko'd or a guy
like sage Northcutt gets Kayode or a guy
like Mighty Mouse gets tagged and has a
real fight on his hands
then you're showing the whole world like
hey these guys that are coming over here
that are world-class fighters they're
fighting world-class fighters I get
knocked out I get that here another it's
a great single for him I think certain
it certain so with Eddie Alvarez veteran
he should be fighting hall-of-famer
Bellator champ UFC champ give him the
best she got he's seen it all to me
tough to get burned past him sage
Northcutt my team asked him the best you
got he's seen it all good luck getting
past him sage Northcutt you're investing
in his future he's not ready you've kind
of [ __ ] them man
well I'm also you try and get an
American market but Kosmos not an MMA
fighter that's the thing
this is cosmos first MMA fight what if
sages takes him down and smashes that
would have been great yeah but I mean
that could have happened - so when
cosmos Ice Age style he's not a grappler
okay but he knows how to crapple say
just taking guys down in the Octagon
before taking cosmo downs easier than
said he's trained with me and Rashad
black ceilings and [ __ ] us up today yeah
it's a nightmare
yeah so I saw it for sage I'm like what
well so he's building Cosmo he's older
man well he's only 34 37 is he three
seven has 1,000 kickboxing matches like
you're gonna invest in that now it's a
business aspect doesn't make sense - I
think it does though because it shows
with two giant results over the last two
months that one has world-class talent
there and I think it makes people pay
more attention to one not me it put me
off of him really yeah [ __ ] up no see
listen man i'ma say no is a [ __ ] Muay
Thai fighter
I mean that's his bread and butter he
fights more time stands his brothers so
when Cosmo goes and fights in an MMA
fight you would think at least in one
area is going to be at a disadvantage if
stay sage chooses to have a stand up
fight
with a world-class stand-up fighter
that's just bad strategy that states
ages game those game but he's a mixed
martial arts fighter then he should
become a kickboxer if that's his game
it's just to stand up and strike at
people then just stay a kickboxer well
because if you're gonna fight listen man
if you're gonna fight in MMA in MMA you
could do everything what do you want to
do in this fight don't you want to win
okay good I want you to win here's how
you win you don't stand with one of the
best [ __ ] strikers in the world how
old is he 22
saij come on yeah yeah but you just tell
him this is strategy you you keep that
side stance that's fine bait him in but
then shoot just get the clinch and drag
that [ __ ] to the ground let's
wear him out I'm with you which he's
never done any fight ever
so put Letty that's taking guys down
before yeah but let's say you serious
manager and they go hey here's Cosmo
hold on let's just let me go through
this with you Sage pros you beat a
straight world-class kickboxer in MMA
he's also 37 years old a lot of pros
cons okay but he's 37 you can take him
down he [ __ ] starches you and your
face is broke in 17 places and your your
career is probably not going well the
trajectories definitely off the rails
those cons that's true it's just if you
look at the way boxing has always done
it and it's been often criticized but
there's some real good points to it
about developing a fighter you give a
guy fighter a difficult fight that you
think that he has the advantage in but
it's an advantage that will teach him to
some things like the phone the guy
fights with them what is this Jimmy
cosmos 9th fight was against age oh he's
had a bunch of MMA fights
well why did he say that he knocks out
everybody he set it on his um his uh his
what the [ __ ] is Instagram post about
he's nobody doesn't fight MMA he's no
[ __ ] on jail buddy I know Jesus
Christ yeah starch everyone well
championship guys here you go yeah years
I guess oh so don't let that fool you
though man because he's training with
the best of the best as well bottom line
is as a striker he's superb yeah he's
[ __ ] but then it's more crazy thing
is pull up the Nicky Holtz can fight
Nicky holtz-eakin knocks out Cosmo
Alexandra that just shows you how many
levels there are two pretending whole
skin just
to region Ursel just lost to him got
dropped with an e it's so interesting
man when you see levels upon levels upon
levels and you don't necessarily know
that these levels even exist unless your
balls deep in the [ __ ] sport like you
see a guy like Nicky first of all
Nikki's like one of the best body
punchers in kickboxing ever and this is
a kickboxing fight as opposed to a Muay
Thai fight as well so no elbows limited
clinching and you can only hold for like
3 seconds when you and throw a knee you
can only like you can only hold while
you're like think one knee at a time or
some like that they have weird rules you
know here's the thing the fact that
Cosmo Alexander went toe-to-toe with
Nikki Holton I'm probably up your ass on
my young 22 year old ya wide-eyed
youngster fighting him Nikki hos can had
an amazing career in glory to some
[ __ ] incredible size Joseph Volta Lee
if I were he knocked him out in the last
round yeah he's a he's a beast man super
to protect although it's just tough as
[ __ ] yeah I mean look at just the way
these guys are standing friendship they
just checking everything technique
perfect perfect perfect defense
oh we dropped him with that left hook
yeah look whole skins I'm a monster and
this is by the way a kickboxing fight
Holtz can also fought Cosmo Alexander
and knocked him out in one Fc this is uh
this is It's Showtime and Amsterdam this
is quite a few years ago It's Showtime
was the [ __ ] managed to get it on access
TV back when access TV was HDNet you
know that Mark Cuban's [ __ ] that was
doping that MMA live with yes I should
go on there all the time
class routing yeah yeah and who's the
other guy that bas Rutten was on with
our boy mauro Rinella no no the other
guy there was another guy who's on Kenny
Kenny rice Henny Kenny rice a rice yeah
that's right yeah
[Applause]